[Musique]
la chine va interdire aux moins de 18
ans de jouer plus de trois heures par
semaine aux jeux vidéo en ligne chez pas
s'il faut s'en réjouir ou parce que
c'est quand même une mesure de dictature
de savoie de dire c'est pas à l'état de
dire qu'en même temps on joue après
c'est aux parents plutôt m'enfin bon en
l'occurrence et ça se passe comme ça en
chine c'est bien la chaîne et puis les
créneaux sont très strictes 1 uniquement
les vendredi samedi et dimanche soir
entre 20h et 21h pas une minute de plus
la mesure ne concerne que les jeux en
ligne sur internet qui sont clairement
les plus addictifs pour les jeunes des
jeux vidéo qualifiée d'opium mentale par
le pouvoir chinois les développeurs de
jeux devraient faire leur travail et
limiter le temps des jeunes en ligne et
vérifier leur identité tee-shirts neufs
les autorités chinoises ont pensé à tout
pour éviter d'éventuelles contournement
des règles côté joueurs une pièce
d'identité sera requise lors de
l'inscription sur une plateforme ensuite
le jeu comparé à la photo du document et
le visage et autorisera ou non l'accès
est dans sa grande clémence le
gouvernement a quand même prévu de leur
accorder une heure par jour en plus
pendant les vacances scolaires c'est
radical radical c'est une torture pour
les gamins c'est quand même une aide
pour les parents en chine figurez-vous
ou une tradition charmante est en train
de revenir dans la nouvelle génération
il s'agit de la tradition du zoo où il y
aussi à huy qui signifie s'asseoir un
mois en fait là moment vient de donner
naissance à un petit bébé ne se lave pas
pendant un mois après la ligue 1
n'est pas encore vaccinés c'est que je
n'ai pas le choix je voudrais avoir le
bac c'est un chinois je voudrais
libre à vous mais
si j'ai un vaccin chinois jeune et il
peut manger dans restaurant chic
ils ont rien aux folles c'est la prière
des statistiques dans l'épidémie
actuelle
vous savez que je rencontre toujours en
faisant mes courses au marché mature
mois pascal praud on fait les courses
aux mêmes heures que moi dans le même
supermarché obama il sait si bien dit
pas à dire ce n'est poliment mais tous
ensemble et met tous en cours du pape et
vous c'est la literie le carrefour du
paf c'est très beau
non mais écoutez bonjour à vous détendre
avec le vaccin si nos ventes est arrivé
tôt chinois
excusez nous
on n'est pas sérieux quand on a 17 ans
mais bon
j'ai pas déjà l'air
ça va bien se passer un truc tu vas dans
la tête dans les salles mais c'est
normal tu fais du cinéma ça fait huit
mois que je te rassure c'est quoi cette
rassure à sion n'a pas du tout
comment est ce qu'on apprend à jouer la
comédie voulait former vos comédiens en
un temps record et ça se plaint pression
qu'on pourrait tout sept vos élèves
d'abord ça se joue dans la respiration
c'est très simple il faut savoir imiter
des singes et faire la vache ça saccade
c'est bien résumé en tout cas
lui aussi ça tire son lot de nos cris
lui c'est guillaume canet s'est écrit
six fois sur la fiche de son nouveau
film
une affiche un brin autocentré fait
remarquer cet internaute un film de
guillaume canet avec guillaume canet
écrit par guillaume canet pour guillaume
canet avec guillaume canet sur la fiche
un long métrage rebaptisé moi sur
twitter où pourrions présenter un
nouveau jeu lorsque le toit en picardie
quoi la présidente karine pourquoi pas
mais on on n'a pas dit notre dernier mot
non moi je moi j'irais pas je n'irai
jamais moi ben non moi non plus voir
mais comme ça nous sommes le 31 août
c'est l'anniversaire de eric zemmour wet
wet zemmour c'est un être comme un
vertige vim
un zeste comme joyeux anniversaire à
léonce employeuse anniversaire examu
joyeux anniversaire merci encore de tête
parmi nous j'ai une petite surprise
comme paulo alors attention oui les
faits faire uniquement pour vous
regardez moi ça
[Rires]
d'artagnan voiler la face bien sûr vous
pouvez vous lever tv
merci bourgeoise anniversaire je pense
que vous êtes l'idiot utile de twitter
en fait on vous met aujourd'hui mais
j'assure pour
[Applaudissements]
incitation à la haine mais là non pas
une espèce haleine mais non franchement
alors évidemment vos tweets sont plutôt
nauséabond et vous vous êtes du côté de
six mois s'il est oui que ce serait du z
et de considération le factice
vous
voilà enfin des mousquetaires et gmail
et anniversaire
vous avez toujours votre épée c'est
votre verbe et hop je nettoie juste
après parce que même nos blagues
respecte le protocole sanitaire on ne
fait aucune brami qu'il respecte pas le
protocole sanitaire important comme
merci au moulin petit peu oui lever les
bras
un petit coup quand même hop et voilà
vous êtes tous alors que je suis dans
une enceinte complètement illégal
puisque je suis enfermé dans une cour de
manière totalement illégale puisque j'ai
trouvé très dans l'établissement un gars
qui a parlé d'un truc était pourtant
ridicule ça pardonne moi les copains et
les frites c'est complètement débile et
des victimes parce que là je suis sur
tout
merci pour faire le sport hippique et le
chou avec moi je viens tu c'est terminé
qu'est ce qu'on va devenir
je vais ajouter la petite sauce
mayonnaise un peu liquide
là est ce que tout le monde est beau
ça rigole jugeant
non mais j'ai paumé mon pantaléon août
c'était déjà arrivé aussi à ça arrive à
des gens très bien
on peut pas livrer bataille et garder
son pantalon serré je le dis moi j'adore
le petit que comme ça on va la garder
grande des causes profondes
on n'est pas français il faut oublier
qu'il n'est pas français des fois ils
sont en panne ont du sens de ces phrases
comme adrien parfois je pensais que moi
tu dors des choses comme ça maintenant
et si vous voulez bien vous tourner chez
arcade qui arrive à charles one vers
sébastien c'est aussi lundi donc tu as
bien manger et toi
avez des grilles tu veux des briques
merci beaucoup à vous johanna et à tout
à l'heure
alors un modèle ou non la météo vous
permettez moi oui pourquoi pas ils
étaient nombreux sujets dont il paraît
au mas barbier je voudrais pas qu'il est
encore un sujet
j'étais trop rapide il est parti trop
vite c'est pas grave c'est direct c'est
le principe c'est le matin on est comme
vous parfois on arrive à se réveiller
des forces rêver un peu moins bien